a lot of procrastinating so but no I
well when I was writing this book I I
listened to ragtime every morning you
know I can't listen to music when I
write I need silence but I like to sort
of use it as a primer and and get myself
back in the time period particularly
with riot time it's such a distinctive
sound that immediately sort of
transports you back into you know a
century earlier so that was really
helpful to me and I tried to I have to
unplug the internet a lot or else I
start surfing like the superficial and
and and Gawker and all these you know
gossip websites and so I'll unplug that
and I need to you know set daily goals
pretty much because my the writing group
is you know we check in with each other
at night and if we don't reach a certain
word goal we're not allowed to sort of
at night we have like a like a wine
toast and if we don't reach our word go
we're excluded from that wine toast and
you get ignored for that night so it's
sort of an incentive you get to hang out
at night only if you get to your you
know you achieve your work